That's the important part of the key.
We can see that this certificate was signed using a signature algorithm.
This is PKCS#1 using RSA encryption--
that's the padding scheme we talked about in Unit 4--and SHA-1 is the hash function.
Then we can see the value of the certificate, and this is it.
We have 1024 bits, and this is what we need to use to convince ourselves
that this is a valid certificate.
Of course, this is actually work that the browsers is doing.
We're really trusting the browser to implement this checking correctly.
What is in this signature?
It is the result of encrypting the hash of the certificate contents,
using the private key of the issuer.
The signature algorithm tells us what we're using for the encryption and the hashing functions.
Both of these are popular but perhaps somewhat questionable choices.
SHA-1 is known to have some weaknesses
that may make it possible for attackers to find hash collisions.
For this quiz, I want you to decide whether or not the certificate contents
that is used as the input to the hash here should include the signature itself.